two weeks ago the Academy's scientific  and technical awards ceremony was held  at the Beverly Hilton Hotel in Beverly  Hills I understand that it is still  going on here with an update the very  clothed rachel mcadams thank you John  over the course of the evening nineteen  awards were handed out including the  Academy's Gordon East our Award  - Gary Dimas for his lifetime of  technological contributions to the  industry  I'm proud to be one of those who works  to help bring new aspects of science and  technology to the creative art ability  me I'm grateful for the opportunity to  work with so many talented people both  technically and artistically I really  deeply appreciate this award thank you  this has been a great night here in  Beverly Hills I'm glad I could be a part  of it